on passe à vos idées de sorties cette
semaine de programme il ya du rock avec
les city guides un spectacle d'humour à
bourges avec les décaféiné l'univers de
tolkien décortiqué par un paléontologue
à chartres mais tout de suite focus sur
monsieur chat il est né à orléans ya 20
ans monsieur chat et nez des griffes de
thoma vuille en 1997
depuis le street artist a décliné son
personnage un peu partout dans le monde
il en a même fait quatre fois le tour
alors pour son 20e anniversaire monsieur
chat prend cette fois la pose sur des
toiles ce qui moi aujourd'hui me fait
rêver en tant qu'humain basse et ses
voyages ça m'a construit dont je me
tiens c'est ça que je peux donner le
meilleur aux gens qui déjà qu'ils
viennent regarder l'exposition et aux
collectionneurs qui veulent des choses
précieuses c'est un peu mais mes trésors
un espace intime et mes trésors
personnels mais trésor de parcours
aujourd'hui thomas vie est l'un des
peintres les plus en vue du street art
avec jonone monsieur chat mondialement
connu ce serait grâce à son sourire
ultra brite
il ya ce sourire mais ça on sait pas si
c'est des fois sourire narquois sourire
inquisiteur sourire joyeux
voilà donc ça c'est un peu une fenêtre
sur sur les sentiments qu'on peut avoir
sur sur ce qui se passe dans le monde
sur ses pas qu'un chat qui fait un
sourire en fait il ya plein de questions
qui skie qui apparaissent en arrière
plan
comment le ravalement en fait ils ont
laissé le
ils ont laissé le petit chat c'est du
lourd que l'air la ville de paris compte
80 grave du matou pain sur le tracé de
la ligne 4 du métro en direction de la
porte d'orléans et orléans c'est le lieu
de naissance de monsieur chat c'est les
chiens d'orléans qu'on baptise m
mon chat monsieur chat puisqu'à l'époque
il n'avait pas de nom c'était juste un
logo un graffiti sur les murs et c'est
le bouche à oreille la rumeur d'orléans
qui a dit liste le mystérieux chat aime
ça et puis c'est resté en fait à orléans
on attend le retour de monsieur chat
pour une grande exposition
mais pour l'instant son 20e anniversaire
ça se fête en levant le nez
les city guides groupe culte de la scène
rock française
ici en 1987 ils ont accepté de se
reformer pour un unique concert qu'il
donne ce samedi soir dans le loiret le
groupe s'est produit à de multiples
reprises dans les années 80 à orléans
autre scène rock très prolifique de
l'époque
[Musique]
les humoristes les décaféiné font le
show ce dimanche au hublot à bourges
leur dernier spectacle se déroule dans
une laverie où l'on papote de
l'actualité bon après faut qu'on
vacances d'après ge a chez lui aussi les
mardis de la science en a 10 avec le
paléontologue jean sébastien steyer en
donnant une conférence sur l'univers de
tolkien et de la saga du seigneur des
anneaux
peut-on modéliser le climat en terre du
milieu pourquoi la hobbit ont-ils de
gros pieds poilus
au cours de cette conférence à l'heroic
fantasy il sera aussi question de
l'évolution de l'espèce humaine
musique sud-africaine l'ensemble foufou
mad love minus est programmée mardi à la
halle aux grains à blois ils pratiquent
licite à camilla une sorte de blues
coraline et au début du 20e siècle de
l'exode rural des zoulous vers les
grandes villes
et comme dans toutes les musiques
populaires on y parle d'amour et de
l'âpreté de l'existence bon week-end à
tous
[Musique]
e